because of donald trump mitch mcconnell
and the republican party their super
majority in the supreme court
american women today have less freedom
than their mothers
with roe
and their attempt to destroy it radical
republicans are charging ahead with
their crusade to criminalize
health freedom
in the congress
be aware of this the republicans
are plotting a nationwide abortion ban
they cannot be allowed to have a
majority in the congress
to do that
but that's their goal
and if you read
and again we're all studying all this
but you read what is in the
very clear
one of the justices had his own
statement
it's about
contraception in vitro fertilization
family planning
that is all what will spring
from their decision that they made today
such a contradiction
yesterday to say the states
cannot make laws governing
the constitutional right to bear arms
and today
they're saying the exact reverse
that the states
can overturn
a constitutional right for 50 years a
constitutional right
for women having the right to choose
the hypocrisy is raging
but the harm
is endless
what this means to women is such an
insult
it's a slap in the face to women about
using their own judgment
to make their own decisions
about their reproductive freedom
and again it goes well i always have
said the termination of a pregnancy is
just their opening act it's just their
front game but because but beyond
behind it and for years i have seen in
this congress opposition to any family
planning domestic
or global when we have had those
discussions and those debates and those
votes on the floor of the house
this is deadly serious
but we are not going to let this pass
woman's right to choose
reproductive freedom
is on the ballot in november
we cannot allow them
to take charge so that they can
institute their goal
which is to criminalize
reproductive freedom
to criminalize it
right now they're saying in states that
they can arrest doctors and all the rest
what is happening here
what is happening here woman's
fundamental health decisions are her own
to make in consultation with her doctor
her faith her family
not some right-wing politicians
that donald trump and mitch mcconnell
pack the court with
while republicans seek to punish and
control women democrats will keep
fighting ferociously to enshrine roe v
wade
into law of the land
this cruel ruling is outrageous and
heart-wrenching
but make no mistake
again
it's all on the ballot in november
the supreme court has ended a
constitutional right this is
50 years
proclaimed a constitutional right
what happened today was historic in many
respects
historic in that
it had
not granted
recognized a constitutional right and
then reversed it
this is a first
and again
just before it imposed a constitutional
right to
allow for concealed weapons
how about those justices coming before
the senators and saying that they
they
respected sorry decisive the president
of the court
that they respected the right of privacy
in the constitution of the united states
did you hear that
were they not telling the truth then